hello everyone and welcome back to
another edition of The Gadget Lab show
I'm Michael colori I'm Nathan olivos
Giles so the next couple of days you're
going to hear a lot of talk from Apple
about who knows what you're going to
hear a lot for Microsoft to have a new
tablet launching they have new phone
system launching they have a new desktop
operating system launching but before
all that happened the big G Google
surprised us with an announcement of a
new piece of hardware and it is this the
new Samsung Chromebook how much does it
cost two hundred and forty nine dollars
wow that's amazing tell me about it and
that's really that's the big story here
it's a two hundred fifty dollar laptop
it's something that has been done but
not quite so well there was the one
laptop per child project which is sort
of the inspiration for this yes this is
used in schools yup sundar pichai who's
actually Google's senior vice president
who oversees all all things chrome
Chrome OS Chrome browser chrome books he
basically talked about you know growing
up in India being amazed by computers
not having access to them until I got to
college and now today wanting to see a
lot of students whether they're in the
US or India with a lot of machines like
this low-cost you know decently fast
computers that can take a beating not
too bad pretty durable and it looks it
looks unabashedly like the the macbook
air macbook air and it's around the same
size it's two and a half pounds yep and
it's about a point eight inches thick
yep has an 11 inch screen and it's it's
not too bad it's a pretty good pretty
good laptop as long as you're living in
Google's ecosystem if you're using gmail
if you're using Google Docs if you're
using google calendar if using Chrome
apps you're going to be right at home
here if you are using you know SkyDrive
and hotmail or if you're using all I
cloud stuff this might not work for you
it's kind of hard to fight against it
like basically show me an Internet user
who's not a google user at this point
but if you don't have a gmail account
then this isn't the device for you
because everything within Google's
operating system is of course you know
tuned to work with Google's devices
tuned to work with chrome OS so you'll
have a great experience on this machine
if you're living entirely within
Google's ecosystem yeah now earlier this
year and actually in in May google
released a 449 dollar Chromebook which
we really liked a lot it's a machine
that I actually still use almost every
single day also made by samsung also
made by samsung that looks a whole lot
like this bring it out of you all right
here it is it's a little bit thicker
it's actually like you know what an inch
thick it's about three ish pounds yellow
on that yeah but there's noble
differences here this new Chromebook the
250r one uses a dual core Exynos
processor from Samsung that's an ARM
processor it's an ARM processor it's
like what you'd see in a smartphone or a
tablet but this older you know slightly
more expensive one uses a traditional
dual-core Intel chip like you'd see in
any other Windows PC or a Mac yeah which
means the fans run like crazy all the
time this has no moving parts inside so
there are no fans that runs super silent
it's a little bit slower than then this
model it's really you know good for you
know email and basic web stuff really
casual surfing a little bit of homework
that's fine but if you want to you know
play a lot of games do some light photo
or video editing you're probably not
going to want to pick this machine up at
all yeah just using this one for a
couple of hours now I've I found it you
have to wait for the page to fully load
before the scroll the before the scroll
action on the trackpad really actually
like fully kicks in and is super
responsive yep yeah it's a little on the
slow side the other piece of Google
hardware is something from Motorola and
it is an android phone yep here we have
the motorola razr HD so it's the latest
motorola smartphone it's a follow-up to
the droid razr that came out last year
so how many razors are there now droid
razr droid razr maxx razr m
razr HD RAZR MAXX HD 500 plus the razor
I six Wow razors in last year a lot of
racers so what's this this one apart
well here basically you have an HD
screen you have a 720p screen which
looks really great it's still a pentile
display so it doesn't look as good as
what you're gonna see like on LCD
displays such as the HTC One X or your
new iPhone 5 or 4s but the pixel density
is so good that a lot of the jagged
edges and you know problems with
contrast you seen a lot of pentel
displays you're not going to see here
unless you're holding the phone like
really close is like a deal breaker for
consumers is it something that when
people go to buy a phone they're like oh
well I have to have this screen or that
screen here this is really the first
pentile displayed that I kind of feel
like I could almost live with the galaxy
s3 also has a pentile display that one's
not too bad it made to feel like I can
almost live with well it looks good it
looks good and it's a fast phone and
it's a great phone but honestly it's
like you know if you bought a brand new
car and you love the way it looks on the
outside and it's fast get some mileage
you want but you know the seats just
don't fit the way that you want you're
going to be sitting it every day you
want to feel comfortable you want to
love this phone for the next two years
of your life Wow good analogy so if your
pick it up go to the store if you like
it you dig it do it but me you know oh
there's there's better display so you're
not sold on the pentile yeah not totally
not totally otherwise it's a great phone
so that you will add that to the stack
of razors and in the meantime you can
check out all of our coverage of the
Microsoft announcement the apple
announcement which is happening on
tuesday you can read our review of the
surface tablet you can check out all of
our coverage on gadget lab and until
then we'll see you next time